hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar spatially defining the future of
cancer biology with Advanced multiplexed
immunofluorescence I am Megan Pascal of
lab roots and I will be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by ultaview to learn more visit
ultaview.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd now like to welcome our speaker Troy
Bloom senior field application scientist
at Ulta view Roy you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much thank you everybody
for joining today
um very nice to be here and giving you
an overview of the Alta View technology
so let me share my screen get here with
me one minute
and
let me go into presenter mode okay here
we go uh so just a little bit about
myself uh again my name is Troy Bloom
I'm a senior field applications
scientist at uh Alta View
um I have over 30 years of experience in
the field of histology uh especially in
IHC and ish assay development uh I
joined Alta View almost two years ago uh
in November of 2020 and then prior to
joining all the view I was the manager
of the histopathology core lab at a
company called acceleron Pharma
um so let's go over uh today's agenda of
what we're going to cover today so uh
first thing is you know how a high
throughput high Plex Multiplex
immunofluorescent assay can more
accurately predict treatment response uh
from there we will go into whole slide
image analysis of the tissue and can
provide insight into the tumor
microenvironment uh then we'll move into
how image analysis can be applied to
Discover cell types populations and
morphological context and then finally
we'll do an application case study okay
so moving forward
uh in this slide right here everybody
has seen a diagram of tumor
microenvironment complexity uh as we all
know you know the tumor micro
environment is the environment around
the tumor uh this is also going to
include the surrounding blood vessels
immune cells fibroblasts signaling
molecules and the extracellular Matrix
um you know the tumor in the surrounding
micro environments are closely related
and will interact constantly uh tumors
can can influence the micro environment
by releasing extracellular signals They
are promoting tumor angiogenesis in
inducing peripheral immune tolerance uh
while the immune cells in the
environment can affect the growth in the
evolution of cancer cells okay
so
uh with the complexity of the tumor
right environment and it's driving the
need for Multiplex markers uh of course
you know as we all know everything is
going to start with the with the basic
hematoxin and eosin stain this is where
uh you know morphology is going to
determine diagnosis and it's as
informative as an h e stain is of course
it doesn't really tell us exactly what
those cells are expressing so you know
from there uh the gold standard is
simple dab IHC right uh and from there
usually we're going to do single protein
detection and then from there we can
start to do cell identity uh or start to
uh do diagnostic algorithms to predict
biomarkers uh and as great as the dab
stain is of course you know at most you
can do one two markers at a time uh but
you know there's a lot more information
in these tissue samples that we're
working with so how do we get there so
now we go from a singleplex dab stain
into a multiplex immunofluorescent stain
and then from there obviously we can
start looking at multiple protein
detection then from there get that
deeper cell phenotyping with the higher
expression range and then of course
intracellular interactions in the
networks around them
so with an overview of tissue based
multiplexed methods uh you know with
that you know the efficient
translational research therefore is
again going to depend on concentrating
resources and molecules and methods more
likely to succeed as biomarkers while
balancing risk of discarding potential
valuable candidate devices prototypes
too early in the development process
so mid-sized panels appear to be the
best methods to keep you in what sweet
spot where you want to be able to
generate big enough data sets with
reliable data to help identify the best
biomarket candidates right so as you can
see you know with number of markers you
could start off with sites off midi
maybe or DSP and then start d-plexing
down to a Alta View technology or TSA
based technology and then of course move
it right into a CDX environment
so just an overview of the LD view
technology it's a very simple uh process
right so after uh sectioning your slides
and baking your slides you move right
into uh the the full protocol uh first
off you're going to start off with a
single antigen retrieval step uh with uh
with the ltvu technology we use a EDTA
Tris based buffer uh pH 9.0 uh that the
protocols uh carried out for uh 20
minutes at 100 degrees C if you're using
a like a bond RX after antigen retrieval
uh you then move into the application of
your antibodies all your antibodies are
going to go into a single cocktail apply
it all at the same time so from there
after you've applied your antibodies we
then go into our amplification step this
of course is a single step this is where
we uh amplify the signal of each of the
unique DNA barcodes that are attached to
each one of the antibodies in your
cocktail and then from there we go into
our detection step
attached to uh each one of these floors
as uh probes is a unique uh floor for uh
the floors that we use are spectrally
distant from each other so that you
don't have to utilize any spectral
unmixing software uh after the fact to
deconvolute the signal and get your uh
your ability to visualize uh the signals
within each and every cell that you're
standing Okay so
moving forward
um
talking about some of the uh available
options that we provide to our customers
uh we have three uh offerings at this
point in time uh the first one is our
fixed view kits uh we have seven all
together uh from there you can then move
into a more flexible kit which is what
we call our flexview kits uh this is
based off of our aplex technology and
our fixed view panels uh where we allow
our customers to swap out up to two
markers uh and select up two markers
from a list of uh 12 markers that you
see on the right hand side and then of
course if you want to do a truly Custom
kit we have those capabilities as well
uh you can select up to eight markers uh
whether from some verified markers that
we currently have in our portfolio or if
there's a marker of your interest that
we don't currently have we can
definitely apply that into whatever Plex
assay that you would like to do
uh but what we're going to focus in on
today is our aplex fixed view kit which
is what we call our Amino eight panel
okay so with this panel of course you
can uh stand up to uh with eight markers
uh the eight markers that are in this
kit are CD3 CD4 cd8 and cd68 along with
Fox P3 pd1 pdl1 and piano cytic keratin
socks 10. uh on below that you can see
that you can start to put together a
multitude of phenotypes uh depending on
uh what your interest lies uh here you
can see there are about 14 phenotypes
that we're showing here uh and again uh
regardless of the uh tissue type or the
disease type that you want to be able to
apply uh these panels to our technology
is very agnostic so as you can see here
in this slide we're showing non-small
cell one cancer a ductal car so in C2
tissue and of course colorectal tissue
one of the nice things I like to point
out about this slide here is that all of
the tissues that you see here uh were
thought stained with the same kit during
the same run so of course you can see
the uh the the flexibility of the kits
and how it can be applied to multiple
tissue types and again even though our
kits uh can are mainly focused in the
immuno oncology field you can utilize
our kits in any disease indication that
you would like to apply it to
so uh now looking a little bit deeper
into uh the predicate comparison uh of
the standing with the markers here uh
within the next couple of slides we'll
cover over all the markers within the
amino weight kit uh so at the top row
you can see we're focusing on four of
the markers in the aplex kit which is
cd8 pd1 pdl1 and cd68 uh you can see
here the dab staining and then from
there we move into our uh single Plex
ISP ISP stands for our technology which
is in c2plex you can see the correlation
between the dab and then the single Plex
uh standing and then we then take an
image from our Multiplex staining as
well and then you can see the
correlation between the the three
staining runs that we did there uh of
course across all four of these markers
here and then moving forward on the next
slide we look at the other markers in
there as well and then of course the
same thing follows start off with dab
follow it up with a monoplex ISP and
then move forward with this uh same
image in the multiplex image just to
show you that uh the staining is
consistent uh for each one of the uh
comparison that we did here
now uh when we start to show some
additional data when we start to look at
intraday assay reproducibility in this
slide we're going to start looking at
single marker positive cell densities uh
you can see that you know with most low
variables it can be observed for cell
counts within one run uh in this
instance we had some slightly higher
values for the cd68 markers here but you
can see that everything is very nicely
uh put together here in in nice
capabilities
um Now with uh with our single micro
positive cell intensities of course with
that we're going to be able to measure
uh the positive cell intensities present
within lower and more even variable
across the markers suggesting that you
know variability observed and soul
counts is in part explained by a
biological variabilities or the
limitations from The Chosen image
analysis okay
uh now moving forward to look more into
some of the phenotype subsets that you
can utilize using our Amino weight
technology uh on this slide you know you
can definitely uh start to explore the
dynamic nature of the tumor micro
environment uh so on this slide right
here you can start to look at the
different subsets that you can do
utilize with our kit whether it's going
to be t-regs exhausted T cells cytotox T
cells or any of the other ones that you
see on there but moving forward
uh once we start to look at some of the
subsets so on this slide we're going to
look at uh some 10 T cells which are
going to be sown in C3 but then if we
want to look at T's helper cells we can
then look at CD3 and CD4 positive cells
uh from there we can start looking at
the t-regs and then add Fox P3 into
there and then of course if you want to
look at your tumor marker which is going
to be the pancit marker you can observe
all of those markers within the tumor
microenvironment and be able to stop
moving forward with your analysis now if
we start looking into some of the other
uh phenotype
that you can look at again we can look
at the pnt cells with CD3 positives move
into the cytotoxic T cells where we add
in cd8s from there we can start looking
at those exhausted T cells where we add
in CD3 with pd1 and then of course not
looking at all four of the markers
together with the cytokeratin marker to
be able to again look at those
populations within the tumor
microenvironment
uh and then if we want to start looking
at some real checkpoint markers we can
start looking at the the
immunosuppressive macrophages where cd68
and pdl1 exist from there we can then
start looking at the immune evading
tumor cells we have cytokeridin and pdl1
positive and then of course again if you
want to look at all three of those
markers together within the term right
environment to give you the nicer
picture of what you're really seeing
before you move into analysis
um so with this technology has been very
popular with a lot of our customers and
researchers and recently
um we had a paper that was uh that was
uh posted uh this year in 2022 uh this
was posted in the Journal of venal
therapy and cancer uh this was a uh a
paper that was put out by the University
of Brussels and basically what they're
doing here is that they utilize our
Amino aid technology to start doing
analysis on five Advanced melanoma
patients using both pre and
post-treatment core needle biopsies
again these samples were staying with
our fixed view Amino weight kit and then
uh what they found out is that following
treatment uh the increase in cytotoxic T
cells densities and regular T cells uh
but then they also saw a decrease in the
exhaustic T cells and immunosuppressive
macrophages uh and then with individuals
with complete remission an increase in t
lymphocyte infiltration was observed so
all this information was done from the
biopsies and then of course the
biomarker for intratrudal treatment
strategies with the signatures of the
Adaptive immune response on early tumor
samples were highly predictive of the
response to treatment so this was a very
nice paper that came out and it showed
the capabilities of our technology when
applied to uh true tissue samples from
patients going through therapies so
how do we leverage multiple fluorescence
well this is where we start to enter the
spatial biology so you know we're going
to start answering three questions the
what which is going to be the spatial
resolved expression of rnas and proteins
with varying degrees of plexing and
retention of tissue cyto architecture
then the Y which is going to enable the
interrogation of complex phenotypes
functional States and intracellular
relationships with help of computational
biology and pathology methods and then
we go into the how which is going to
borrow Concepts into statistical
modeling techniques from geography and
ecology right so
um now at alty view you know we are a
spatial biology company uh definitely
specialized in spatial phonomics uh you
know we're definitely positioning
ourselves around leading this push into
the spatial phonomics area with that you
know it's definitely going to provide
discipline of mining tissues images in
their own context to identify spatial
patterns that are related to clinical
outcomes and involves every step from
start to finish so this is going to
include development of the assays
analysis of the images and then of
course providing the spatial biology uh
going further into Data Mining and then
of course uh validation of those
findings okay
so
again without the view we are able to
support your journey through the entire
developmental pipeline you know starting
at the beginning with the finding and
framing your specific scientific
question in developing your panel of
markers all the way through to
delivering answers that enable your
project to move forward
um again we can begin by helping you
define your specific question
and then once we understand your
specific question we can begin
developing your assay you know whether
you want to choose from the available
panels or see how one of our Flex View
or custom assays may be able to answer
your specific question
now uh you know each one of our kits
whether it's a fixed view Flex View or
our uview catalogs are pre-optimized and
they are to uh develop to produce quick
turnaround times producing optimizing
clear signals for your images uh you
know we can do this with up to an eight
biomarkers on whole slide Imaging with
clear cellular resolution and again
these high Flex stains show you detailed
phenotypic profiles and the localization
of these cells within their micro
environments and our essays are gentle
enough to run a true h e stain on the
same slide so you can have that classic
pathologist annotation as well as the
detail hyplex analysis this provides you
with a large amount of cellular
information
so you know we can take all of this
information and use images or data
analysis to look more closely at the
biology happenings Within These tissues
now as we discussed before uh we can do
update mile markers but in this example
here we're going to show you a piece of
tissue that we've stained up with a 12
Plex assay that we currently run in our
services lab again we're going to be
looking at 12 biomarkers on whole slide
images along with the h e stains with
Pathologists annotations again this is
going to provide us with a lot of data
points for analysis
now uh we can start with the classic h e
for pathologist annotations to determine
tumor regions however with a company's
Multiplex fluorescent images we can dig
a Little Deeper right
so we start with a simple dappy uh
showing all the cells within the region
and then add the tumor regions in red
this of course is a run on the whole
slide uh so again whole slide is shown
in the upper left hand corner and we
have the overlay shown the analyze
Cellular localizations in the cell
phenotypic profile in the circle which
is in the lower left hand corner okay
now uh now we want to start looking at T
cells which are again going to be shown
here in green and they're going to show
you that some have infiltrated into the
tumor regions which you can see within
the white circle and some have remained
in the non-tumor compartment okay so if
you look outside of the tumor
compartment you can see that you're
going to see some of those T cells
expressing out there and with any
additional markers we can start to
differentiate these T Cell populations a
little further
so now we bring in our site to talk to T
cells which is going to be shown here in
light blue and this is paired now with
the macrophage stain and now the
macrophane stain which is now here in
purple which can show these immune cell
clusters which have been primed by
antigen presenting cells and now within
the tumor regions in position to attack
those tumor cells but what is a pdl1
stain was applied
which is now shown here in yellow and
now we can see these tumor cells have
responded by expressing pdl1 which is
then going to be categorized as within
the immune tumor cells and then these
patients might be a good candidate for
an anti-pedal1 therapies right
so uh with these stains along with the
proper analysis you can give a much
better picture of what is occurring
within the tumor microenvironment so as
this captures here you can definitely
see utilizing image analysis you can
start to segment these cells be able to
categorize them and then again move
forward and then uh you know as we can
do this on the real cells we can
actually see or quantify all of these
cellular interactions within the tissue
here's just highlighted five markers to
answer one particular question as I
mentioned before these tissues was
actually run with the 12 biomarkers
which provides you with even more data
and a clearer picture about the tumor
micro environment and exactly what is
happening within the tissue so you can
have a better understanding for drug
Discovery or patient treatment for
example
um now again here are just some of the
examples of what we can do with all of
this data
you know and just run it quickly you run
a simple whole slide cell quantification
which can then provide you with uh
whatever amount of information you want
to provide whether it's going to be
total cells how many of those are tumor
cells which ones are the T cells how
many of those are cytotoxic which one's
a macrophage and then of course if
you're interested in pdl1 how many of
those cells are expressing a pdl1
uh from there you know we can then
generate a detailed phenotypic analysis
for all of the cell types present
and then we can break the tissue up into
compartments in this example here we'll
start breaking up in this tumor versus
non-tumor okay
and then using these defined tumor and
non-tumor regions we can start to look
at the cell populations within those
regions this is going to highlight the
importance of location data for example
information about the immune cells
infiltrating the tumor borders can help
determine whether a tumor is classified
as hot or cold and this is going to
indicate whether it's a potential for
targeted therapies however we don't just
have to stick to just tumor versus
non-tumor
we can then start to segment it into
more detail regions and analyze the cell
populations within regions like this
example here we can split the stroma up
into three different immune evading
populations a cold or non-infiltrated
region which is going to be shown here
in the blue uh and then of course uh
after that you know we can start in
either import structures for example
shown here in red or cell clusters shown
here in the green okay
now from there we can start to look at
cell clustering throughout these tissues
here there are two different tissue
regions with similar cell numbers
however in the region on the right where
T cells can spread out and generate more
cell to cell interactions in a larger
cell response as opposed to a more
clustered T Cell population shown on the
left
now the spatial data is key to
determining exactly what is occurring in
the tissue so distance analysis can
provide insights into how active the
immune response is in a tissue in this
example a regulatory T Cell shown in the
gray can regulate T cells shown in green
and as long as they are in the same
vicinity
uh the T cells which which are outside
of the region or not close might be
activated and uninhibited and free to
roam and kill tumor cells so all of
these analysis can tell you a lot about
your tissue
uh from there you know we are then able
to summarize with an expert analysis and
a report and help get you specific
answers
uh you know in our image analysis
packages we provide uh quite a bit of
information for you to be able to
utilize to make the determinations on
your research uh you know starting with
same slide fluorescent and H E image
Fusion uh from there we can then do
whole slide image analysis which
includes multiple microphenotyping uh if
you were to do a four Plex we can
provide up to eight phenotypes if you
were to move forward with an A plus you
can definitely do up to 16 phenotypes uh
from there we can also provide you with
tissue segmentation which will
definitely be like tumor versus
non-tumor utilizing our CK Sox 10 uh
cocktail antibody from there we can
definitely provide a spatial phenomics
report uh with the standard readouts
including cell quantification cell
densities marker intensities and for
whole slide tissue or tumor versus
non-tumor
uh so with the spatial phonomics uh
visualization of complex phenotypes
using uh anatomic pathology workflows uh
again quantification quantitation and
spatial analysis of cell phenotypes uh
then we can do correlation of cell
phenotypes densities and proximities
with tissue morphology uh followed that
up with discovery of new cellular and
tissue biomarkers and then of course
training of artificial intelligence deep
learning networks to improve
interpretation of h e slides
and that is pretty much the end of the
presentation
um so I will hand it back over
um and we can start answering any
questions
great thank you so much Troy for your
informative presentation if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
does Ulta view provide recommendations
for the best 404 combinations for
co-localized markers that are expressed
within the same cell for example CD3 and
cd8
yeah great question so we can definitely
provide you with uh the right
fluorophores to utilize uh again with
the LTD view technology because we use
the four distinct floors uh that
especially different from each other
they're going to help you visualize
those cells uh more easily and clearly
uh and then from there of course you
know we can definitely work with you to
uh work with the best combinations of uh
either floors or pseudo colors moving
forward but again the floors that we
currently use are Fitzy Trixie site five
and size 7 along with dappy as a nuclear
markers
great thank you my next question have
you tested other sample types beyond
ffpe for example fresh Frozen
yeah great question uh so uh currently
at alty view uh our assay is developed
mainly around formally fixed paraffin
beta tissues uh we have not currently
worked out a a working process for
Frozen tissues however we have worked
with various customers who have utilized
our technology on their Frozen samples
and uh they have provided us with a
great input and have shown some positive
data that has come from some of that
standing so um
awesome
um is there a better way to stack my
sequential images Beyond using dappy
yeah so uh currently at ulti view uh we
have uh software that we've developed
in-house which is what we call our ulti
stacker stuff software uh and what
basically happens here is that uh you
basically take each round of your stains
and the software will stack these images
utilizing uh the dappy signal or the
nuclear content signal from uh each one
of the rounds that you've stained for so
in an instance of an apex uh it'll take
the first round of staining and then the
second round of staining and then line
up the nuclear stain on both of those
rounds to get that composite moving and
then of course if you wanted to come
back and do a true H knee uh you can
then stack the third round with the H
knee together with your first two rounds
of Multiplex immunofluorescent staining
and then of course get that nice
composite of the multiplex with the h e
great it looks like we have one more
question here if I have my own IHC
qualified antibodies can Ulta view
develop a custom kit
yes we can as I said earlier with our
truly custom you view offering uh you
can choose either one of our verified
markers from the panel or if you have
one of your own IAC qualified antibodies
we can definitely Implement that into
whatever Plex assay that you would like
to have developed
great and it looks like that brings us
to the end of our q a portion of the
webinar thank you so much Troy do you
have any final comments for the audience
uh all I'd like to say today is uh thank
you for your time we really appreciate
it uh hopefully uh this was very
informative for you and then of course
if you have any questions please reach
out to us we are readily available to
answer any questions uh and engage you
in any conversations with any future
research that you would like to utilize
the LTV technology on
great thank you again Troy for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor ultaview for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye